[Musique]
bonjour je saigne vignard animatrice
d'ateliers culinaires chef à domicile
j'adhère à la marque poitou déjà depuis
un an et demi et je suis ravi de vous
accueillir aujourd'hui pour vous
présenter marre aussi de la nuit du
poitou charentes à la moutarde à
l'ancienne et au vin blanc
donc pour réaliser cette recette il nous
faut 3 échalotes 2 petits oignions la
couper en morceaux
2 gousses d'ail du vin blanc 20
centilitres du vin vendu au pourtour de
l'huile d'olive vincenti les deux crème
fraîche liquide du romarin du jardin et
de l'épaule d'agneau que j'ai découpé en
petits morceaux devenus mariné et
environ 30 minutes entre oculaire à ceux
de moutarde à l'ancienne tout on allume
notre cocotte on sur feu assez vif on
met un petit peu d'huile d'olive
la moitié de la tasse à café on va faire
bien revenir l'huile d'olive et quand
lui il va être bien chaude on va mettre
nos échalotes notre union hainaut tribe
qu'on va faire bien bien revenir
finement coupés en petits morceaux
voilà on est qui vient venir on ajoute
aussi les petits oignons pareil pour
faire et on ajoute les deux petites
gousses d'ail on a aussi coupé en petits
morceaux de gras sur des germes et 1 et
ont très bien revenir tout ça on attend
que ça chante bien dans la pétrole quand
tout va bien revenez on va ajouter notre
agneau vous voyez en fait j'ai fait des
petits dés comme ça voilà pas trop gros
pour que sa fille assez rapidement quand
même donc on ajoute bien notre radio
on va mélanger voilà pour bien faire
dorer
n'hésitez pas pour une question assez
grande pour bientôt
des morceaux qui chauffe eau mélangée
bien la voilà donc voilà maintenant
comment sont sont bien dorés on va
ajouter 20 centilitres de vin blanc du
haut poitou et voilà et là on laisse
c'est bien mouillé la voilà ça recouvre
bien la viande normalement on va ajouter
nos deux branches de romarin
voilà on va mettre un peu de sel alors
pas trop parce qu'il ya quand même
lamentable qui va déjà salée notre
viande est un peu de poids alors pareil
ça trou lorsqu'il ya déjà la moutarde
mais après ça aussi selon vos goûts
voilà et là on va laisser tous à mijoter
pendant au moins une heure et demi donc
à surveiller et on rajoute on peut
rajouter un peu d'eau si on voit que ça
attaches mais pendant ce temps là on va
glacer nos petits navets nos carottes
qui vont faire l'accompagnement de notre
plat des effets précuire avant à la
vapeur pour leur donner la somme et
moelleux et comme ça on va juste à voir
aller glacée dans l'huile d'olive
ils vont être tout fondant et pour
accompagner les ans nous c'est un vrai
délice donc pour ça vous allez prendre
une poêle on va mettre un petit peu
d'huile d'olive
on va bien la laisser revenir donc voilà
on va déposer bien nos carottes voilà
dans l'huile d'olive ont l'art tombe
bien on entend que ça frétille
donc c'est parfait voilà je m'étais bien
voka mois les petits n'avaient pas là et
on y retourne bien dans l'huile d'olive
voilà pour qu'il dort de tous les côtés
brille on va les assaisonner un petit
peu donc un peu de poids un peu de sel
dans cinq dix minutes on les enlèvera
donc après une bonne heure et demie de
cuisson voilà l'agneau et tout temps on
voit qu'il se détache un peu et à la
sauce que là où la bonne odeur qui ont
déjà l'eau à la bouche
donc là maintenant on va rajouter no 20
centilitres de crème liquide
voilà ça c'est pour adoucir un peu la
sauce pour donner un peu d'eux et
d'onctuosité donc on va bien mélanger et
après vous allez laisser revenir encore
cinq ou dix minutes pour que ça
s'évapore et que la viande et le temps
et que la crème étant de bien imprégné
les morceaux de viande pour mettre le
couvercle et ensuite on va passer au
dressage vous voyez au petit morceau de
viande on voit encore le petit morceau
de n'doye nyon et d'échalotes donc on va
déposer un peu beaucoup de pions et là
on va déposer des petites carottes
encore une puisque on est gourmand des
petits navets et voilà un mijoté
d'agneau du poitou charentes la moutarde
et au vin blanc et je vous dis à bientôt
pour une nouvelle recette
[Musique]